speaking for the grotesques I'd have to
disagree death is so final where's the
life our life is full of possibilities I
hope the boy does wake now be very
interested to hear what he has to say my
dear brother
our time should make me wonder whose
side you're on what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back for another Game
of Thrones Season 8 prediction video
today I want to talk about our favorite
imp Tyrion of House Lannister most of
you should know that I had been making a
ton of predictions about how I think
Game of Thrones will end I have talked
about a number of different scenarios I
can see playing out but I haven't really
talked about what I think Tyrion can do
yet Tyrion is one of the main characters
in this show so he should definitely
have a big role to play in the final
season now that the night king is south
of the wall they will need all the help
they can get in order to survive we have
seen Tyrion fight in a war during the
Battle of Blackwater Bay but I don't
think we will be seeing him on the
battlefield during this one because
there is something else I believe Tyrion
can do to help I think they will find a
way to defeat the night king and I
believe Tyrion will assist them with
this major discovery now if you've seen
any of my other videos you would know
that I believe salmon brain will
continue to work together in order to
find out something about stopping the
night king and his army thanks to
Samwell Tarly he's the one that told
brain about Rhaegar and Lyanna secret
wedding and that's how brand knew where
to look to find out the truth about
Jon's parents and I believe their
teamwork will continue because together
they can figure out how to beat the
night king Sam can continue to read his
books that he took from the Citadel and
when he finds out some important
information about the night king he can
tell bran and bran can look and see how
it was done before but I think Tyrion
can help also the main reason why I
think this is because of a few things
that happen during the very first season
of this show everything that happened
with Tyrion back then is about to come
full circle in the final season
Tyrion Lannister and brain stark
storylines were heavily intertwined in
the first season
after bran stark was pushed from the
tower Tyrion was very interested in what
actually happened because he knew it was
in an accident Tyrion was also hoping
that bran would live and he wanted to
make sure some compassion was shown to
the Starks because of this tragic thing
that happened to their son and that was
of course when we got that great scene
when Tyrion slept the [ __ ] out of
Joffrey because Tyrion wanted him to go
pay his respects your absence has
already been noted or means nothing to
me I can't stand the wailing of women
one word and it's you again I'm telling
mother go in the next episode that's
when we see Tyrion traveling to the wall
with Jon Snow and that's where they
started to bond
all of these building blocks were being
put together very early on and this is
very important because all of this led
to them working together today after
Tyrion left the wall he went back to
Winterfell and this is when we learned
that Tyrion had a soft spot for cripples
bastards and broken things I really be
able to write you win on horseback
you'll be as tall as any of them this is
some kind of trick why do you want to
help him I've a tender spot my heart
cripples bastards and broken things
he didn't my brother of kindness
although the Starks and the Lannisters
hated each other
Tyrion did like brain and Jon he saw
things and both of them that he saw in
himself jon was a bastard and bran was a
[ __ ] and he knew people would treat
them just like people treated him
and this is why Tyrion took a liking to
them and this is very important because
Jon never forgot that and neither will
bran the crazy thing is Tyrion almost
died because of brand lady Catelyn
accused Tyrion of hiring the cat's ball
to kill bran and Tyrion was very close
to getting thrown out of the moon door
because of this but I don't think I need
to give a bunch of examples for you to
see that Tyrians entire plot in season 1
revolved around bran stark and Jon Snow
I think this is very interesting because
now that we are heading into the final
season we will see this happen again
Tyrians early ties to brains
darken the first season will come into
play next season Tyrion will see brain
and Sam together and he's gonna want to
help because Tyrion knows he is much
more effective with a book in his hand
instead of a sword in his hand Tyrion
said as much to Jon in the first season
when they were travelling to the wall
together why'd you read so much look at
me and tell me what you see this is a
trick well my brother has his sword and
I have my mind and a mind needs books
like a sword needs a whetstone that's
why I read so much Jon Snow Tyrion is
one of the most intelligent characters
in this show and if there is anything
that can be found in those books sam has
then tyrion can help them find it i
believe they will find the secret to
defeating the night king because of
something sam said last season now some
people may have missed this because most
of the people were focusing on something
else during this conversation right
before Sam left the Citadel this was
when Gilly told him about Rhaegar
cinoman but that wasn't the only
important thing said during that scene
they sent me to the task of preserving
that man's wind accounting and
annulments and bowel movements for all
eternity
well the secret to defeat in the 90s but
we sitting on some dusty shelf somewhere
completely ignored but that's alright
isn't it we can all become slathering
murderous imbeciles in thrall to evil
incarnate as long as we can have access
to the full records of High Septon
maina's fifteen thousand seven hundred
and eighty-two [ __ ] did you hear what
Sam said he said the secret to defeating
the night king is probably just sitting
around on some dusty shelf somewhere
being completely ignored I think this
was one of the most important scenes of
foreshadowing because in the very next
scene Sam goes into the library and
takes all kinds of old books off of
those dusty shelves then he left and
went straight to Winterfell
next season we are going to learn
exactly what is in those books and Sam
isn't the only one who is book savvy
Tyrion is as well and we've been told
this since the very first season this
was a big part of who Tyrion was as a
character when Tyrion arrives in
Winterfell at the very beginning of this
show and at the
very beginning of the books one of the
first things he does is go to their
library to read and check out books and
now it's finally time for Tyrion to
start putting all of this knowledge he
has to use Tyrion took a lot of losses
last season all of his plans went
completely to [ __ ] Tyrion was being
outmaneuvered at every turn and it got
to the point to where Daenerys stopped
taking his advice
so Tyrion needs to redeem himself if you
die we're all lost everyone everything
you told me to do nothing before and I
listened to you I'm not doing nothing
again
once again he needs to show everyone how
useful he still is he might not be able
to slay the night King on the
battlefield but he can't help figure out
a way to defeat him and I think this
will be his purpose during the Great War
we know Sam and bran will continue to
work together but I think Tyrion will
join them when he sees Sam with all of
the old books from the Citadel he's not
going to be able to help himself people
used to think Tyrion was going to be one
of the three heads of the Dragon
but now the Vissarion is dead and being
ridden by the night king that theory is
out the window but that doesn't mean he
still can't step up and do something big
but let me know what you think what do
you believe Tyrion will be doing during
the Great War will he be out there on
the battlefield or will he help Sam and
bran find a way to stop the night Cain
put all your thoughts and questions down
below in the comment section I want to
thank everyone for stopping by to watch
the video I really appreciate that and I
also want to thank all of my new patreon
supporters I can't thank you all enough
for your contributions over the months
have a great day everyone
I will see you in the next one bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]